I'm back. The last time I've been on TikTok
talking about the manosphere and all that good stuff
was probably July.
My man and my kid come first,
so I had to take away some valuable family time.
Also, I'm having another baby in, like,
less than three months.
Yep. I am a full seven months Pregers.
And on top of all of that,
I started thinking one.
I was doing a lot of homesteading stuff,
and I wanted to find a way to make more money from home.
As y'all know,
I have traditional values,
and I ain't putting my kid in the daycare.
2 politically and socially,
we complain so much about
women not staying at home anymore.
The Manosphere's only solution is
go back to your 20s and find a high value man.
So for the rest of us women
stuck out here in the real world,
where are all the solutions?
Where are the problem solvers
of this? Now,
a lot of y'all are super negative,
but there is a plethora of people
and influencers actually
trying to help shape and change culture. After all,
that's how we got to this position to begin with.
So I started a community
for women wanting to work from home.
It's in the most lucrative industry of 2023 and 2024,
and I'm killing it.
Anyway, that is my late night update.
I took some family time,
I got pregnant.
I started a full business in digital marketing
with a Big community of women.
And now it's time to branch out to my people
on the TikTok.
I'll see y'all down the road.